monsieur le préfet mon cher philippe
richert tu mon cher frédéric guéry chers
collègues conseillers départementaux du
bas rhin et du haut rhin les chers
collègues parlementaires
rené danesi et guy dominique kennel qui
nous font l'honneur de participer à nos
travaux et claude kern pardonnez moi que
je n'avais pas perçu il me revient donc
l'honneur de conclure nos travaux très
provisoirement bien sûr car j'en suis
convaincu notre réunion commune
d'aujourd'hui en appellera bien d'autres
elles seront sans doute moins symbolique
car débarrassé du privilège de la
première première pour notre mandature
mais sans doute aussi constructive et
génératrice d'avancées concrètes et
visibles aux yeux de nos concitoyens je
les à nouveau constaté et surtout
apprécié ce matin à travers la richesse
de nos échanges il reste énormément de
choses à faire ensemble
j'ai en effet l'intime conviction que ce
qui rassemble nos deux départements est
beaucoup plus important que ce qui les
sépare le land grab n'est rien face à la
majesté du haut koenigsbourg que ceux
qui sont bien passées peuvent apercevoir
à ma gauche et qui du haut de sa colline
nous invite à encore plus et encore
mieux collaborer ensemble des fouilles
archéologiques récemment effectué par le
père notre structure commune l'ont
confirmé à l'époque romaine nous étions
ici chez les rauraques et vous très
chère amie d'harry noir vous étiez chez
lederrey tribaux à colmar et strasbourg
existait à peine
et les capitales étaient respectivement
à ox tu en suisse et à brumath pour ma
news il parait il paraît que rauraques
et reebok ne s'entendait pas bien il
faut dire qu'à l'époque la défense de
l'identité alsacienne était la dernière
de leurs préoccupations
mais aujourd'hui deux millénaires plus
tard l'alsace des rauraques et d'être
ebook est définitivement relégué dans
les livres d'histoire nous avons déjà
démontré notre capacité à collaborer
activement lors des années qui ont
précédé la démarche conseil d'alsace
il en a résulté de belles réalisations
de mise en commun d'expériences et de
procédures notamment matière économique
ainsi que des rapprochements dans des
politiques ciblées
j'adore ainsi pleinement aux propos tout
à l'heure de notre collègue bernard
fischer sur alsa bail qui constitue un
outil économique essentiel pour notre
région
à côté des agences de développement
économique
le quart aussi a eu sa part dans ses
réussites économiques très récemment il
a permis un investissement de plus de
150 millions tout près d'ici à design
chez constellium et la création de 60
emplois
certains veulent effacer l'histoire du
conseil unique pour faire oublier leur
position qui a tellement nuit à l'alsace
la sanction en a été sévère
c'est la disparition pure et simple de
l'alsace en tant que collectivité mais
le temps est désormais venu d'aller plus
loin avec encore plus de détermination
car comme cela a été déjà dit et répété
à plusieurs reprises le contexte dans
lequel s'inscrit le nécessaire
rapprochement
entre deux conseils départementaux à
très profondément évoluer le cadre
institutionnel est désormais et
peut-être provisoirement je ne sais pas
celui de la grande région alsace
champagne ardenne lorraine à l'échelle
de laquelle il conviendra désormais
d'envisager qu'on le veuille ou non les
stratégies locales de développement
économique
c'est en effet au conseil régional que
la loi notre a confié les compétences
dans ce domaine et tu viens de le
rappeler ce cadre institutionnel est
aussi celui de l'eurométropole de
strasbourg au rayonnement et aux
compétences renforcées
c'est également celui de département au
rôle concentré dans le domaine de la
solidarité par la loi neutre alors que
l'on prédisait leur prochain sacrifice
sur l'autel de la réforme territoriale
même si rien ne dit qu au final le
gouvernement n'atteindra pas son funeste
objectifs par des voies financière
détourner les départements sont toujours
là avec un cadre budgétaire qui s'est en
effet considérablement dégradées sous
l'effet cisaillant de l'explosion des
dépenses sociales non compensés et de la
baisse draconienne des dotations de
l'état
certes nos collectivités ont appris
depuis plusieurs années à vivre en apnée
financière elle s'isole et elles s'y
sont adaptés en faisant des économies
en agissant mieux avec moins mais quand
on cherche à les asphyxier
elles se débattent mieux elle se bat
c'est précisément chers collègues
ce que nous proposons de faire frédéric
bierry et moi même nous battre tous
ensemble afin d'être plus fort face à
l'adversité
qu'elles soient économiques ou
économiquement ou politiquement
organisée
nous battre avec nos moyens mais des
moyens additionner conjuguer voire
peut-être des moyens mutualisés
lorsque les conditions seront réunies
pour le permettre
des moyens qui pourront être d'autant
plus commun que leur mise en oeuvre aura
été précédée de démarche de concertation
rendant possible au final des
convergences de vues sur les principales
politiques menées par nos deux
départements
nous le savons nos concitoyens attendent
de nous des initiatives qui tendront à
réduire la dépense publique
il attend de nous des économies
d'échelle des suppression de doublons
dans nos interventions respectives de
démarche de rationalisation des coûts
le tout dans le respect des territoires
qui font l'alsace
il y a évidemment strasbourg mais il ya
aussi mulhouse il y à colmar ya sélestat
et haguenau et toutes les autres
communes
à cet égard sachons pour mieux fédérer
nos intelligences et partager nos
expériences
sachons également étendre à d'autres
domaines de compétences
le pragmatisme et le réalisme qui
préside au rapprochement aujourd'hui
actes et de nos agences touristiques
économiques
celui ci permettra notamment une
collaboration optimisé avec l' agence
d'attractivité d'alsace sachons ainsi
mieux défendre ensemble les héritages
historiques
cela a été rappelé à plusieurs reprises
et les spécificités géographiques de
notre belle région
sachons encore mieux nous entendre afin
de mieux parler et ce dans la même
tonalité
sachons enfin faire porter jusqu'aux
limites occidentale de la grande région
et jusqu'aux limites orientale des
territoires allemands et suisses qui
nous sont voisins cette fois d'une voie
d'une alsace forte de ses valeurs de son
identité de sa culture et de ses atouts
économiques
vous voyez chers collègues je crois
deviner entre les lignes des débats et
des résolutions adoptées au cours de
cette séance les prémices d'une belle et
longue collaboration cette réunion
refaire revers en effet à mes yeux et je
l'espère aux vôtres également une triple
importance
d'abord une importance symbolique à
travers les messages possible positif et
constructif adressé à nos concitoyens
ceux d'une volonté partagée de relever
ensemble les défis financiers et
budgétaires qui se présente à nous
ensuite une importance stratégique grâce
au sort et aux orientations que veut
nous que nous venons d'adopter dans les
domaines économique et touristique et
qui pose les fondations la fois d'une
meilleure coopération entre nos
départements et d'un dialogue enrichi
avec les agglomérations et la futur méga
région enfin une importance
opérationnelle grâce au cover engeance
politique que nos échanges et nos
résolutions rendront possible et grâce à
l'occasion qui nous a été donné
aujourd'hui pour certains d'entre nous
de mieux nous connaître
ceci n'est ni un début ni une fin ni un
grand soir ceci est juste la continuité
naturelle et renforcé de ce qui a déjà
été entrepris une nouvelle étape dans
une démarche essentielle celle d'une
mise en cohérence de notre vision de
l'avenir de l'alsace est celle d'une
mise en pertinence partager des moyens
pour y parvenir
en espérant évidemment que la future la
future grande région saura comme nous le
serons être attentive au développement
et aux initiatives de nos territoires
dans toute leur diversité
rien qu'en cela cette séance a été des
plus fructueuses et des plus
enrichissantes et ce grâce à la présence
et la participation active de chacun
d'entre vous je tenais à vous en
remercier très sincèrement ainsi que
tous les partenaires et services qui se
sont associés à cette démarche
que vive l'alsace et vive la france